hello friends right this video is
admittedly long overdue as I've noticed
throughout time there's a bit of
confusion or at least misconception
towards my rating system either case my
fault should've done this video a long
time ago should I clarify but to get the
full story you have to go back to a time
in 2010 please hear me to talk about it
here so I came up with my rating system
in 2010 after about a year of being on
YouTube I wanted to do something fun
nothing with numbers or stars or grades
or anything like that I wanted to do
some fun sentence based writings that
would kind of show people how I viewed
the movie rather than where it placed on
hierarchy so I created it and never
really address it again which means
there are over a million subscribers of
mine but we're just left there with no
context of my rating system just had to
create context as I saw it so hopefully
after this video will all be on the same
page or at the very least we will have a
video so if someone comments this movie
a good time y'all require was the other
movie buy it on blu-ray as is Greg we
now have a video for contact sake that
we can politely point the person to whom
you're like here's what you're missin so
my rating system as I believe is
perceived to something like this a list
of ratings in a sequence from worst to
best like any other rating system
comparable the stars grades points
whatever but this isn't how I initially
envisioned it I initially envisioned it
something more like this awards or
titles to be given out based on no order
whatsoever
a rather context maybe I'd buy it on
blu-ray maybe the movie would be better
if you're drunk actually initially maybe
it was a little more like this because
let's face it is the bottom of
the barrel and awesome tacular as far as
one can define this made-up word not
found in the dictionary is the coolest
of the cool that washing tacular does
not mean technically perfect
it's just movies that I really connect
with or hit me on a personal or fan boy
level that's why it always cracks me up
in a review where I give a movie an
awesome tacular maybe it's spider-man
homecoming people are like hey this
movie's awesome jangler's this guy's
such an if you're moving in character a
franchise title here fanboys yeah pretty
much but other than those ends of the
spectrum everything in the middle is
just kind of a label that I would give a
movie in their writings because I said
their writings and I guess we kind of
all agree that the writing so they lack
that definitive structure that makes a
rating system a rating system like a
letter grade system or a numerical
system it's kind of why I like it it's
fun but if I'm being honest regardless
of initial intent there was always
structure to it I'm moving comparable
the dog shits not good we already said
neither's are forgettable movie a movie
I would buy on blu-ray is probably not
bad no where's the movie that is a good
time sans alcohol and this is where that
confusion is is that shuffle in the
middle of what writings are above or
below other writings you see numerical
alphabetical or star rating system is
quantifiable you know what a movie with
a b-grade is because B is lower than a
and above C always you know what a seven
out of 10 is because seven is above six
and below eight always star rating
systems are numerical rating systems
just with pictures but we know what it
is and we can quantify that because we
have an alphabet and a numerical system
that we use in our daily life there's no
such structure for this that's
personally what I found most fun about
it and you may be saying well that's not
very useful for a rating system yeah
you're right it's not really useful for
a writing system it's the kind of fun
that someone with 6,000 subscribers in
2010 on YouTube would create for fun
it's as Wild West as the YouTube
platform of 2010 that spawned it was he
always felt that numerical rating
systems or letter grade rating systems
lock movies or reviews into a box if you
can quantify it then you can about
it it's moving got a B but that movie
got a see I've only got a seven when
that movie got it a subscribe and I
wanted to avoid that though I've failed
miserably at avoiding that but it's just
fun to have ratings that's why I like
having a rating system every movie
review or video game review I watch on
YouTube there is one constant in every
review bar none no exceptions
hands down the constant is I always try
to guess what the ratings going to be
before it comes up on screen every time
but I figured AHA as I can talk about if
the movie is good or bad in my review
the ratings will be titles they won't
lock themselves into a hierarchy like
imagine a school assembly I don't know
if your school did this my school did
this where the teacher be like alright
so the award for perfect attendance goes
to Timmy and the award for most improved
homework goes to Johnny you can't really
compare those awards but those are
awards that are allocated can't imagine
some parent being like okay give me that
award when you gave my son this is one
way you can just not really comparable
given that context is how I saw it then
and that's how I see it now though there
is a line between good and bad that I'll
get to in a second but a movie that I
would buy on blu-ray is simply a movie
that I would buy on blu-ray movie that
I'm not
remember as a movie that I'm just
probably gonna forget but there are
great fantastically made masterpieces of
cinema that I don't feel the urge to
watch again and they don't hit me at a
deep personal level so what's left well
it's a good time no alcohol required as
that's now seen as the middle of the
road kind of positive review that would
be insulting I feel like you'd kind of
be seen as oh hey here great movie
here's the middle of the road positive
review I didn't intend that rating to be
the middle of the road positive review
personally I think Siskel and Ebert hit
the Goldilocks zone of writings is the
movie good is it not thumbs up thumbs
down every review out there since the
history of reviews works to get to that
end goal you take any eight-minute
review out there it boils down to one
thing is it worth watching or is it not
any review can be three seconds long
however long it takes to say that
everything in the review is padding to
give context to that end reason it
thumbs up or thumbs down well honey to
write exists or where it's like if you
skip to the end you don't necessarily
know what I felt about the movie good
timing for drunk what the does that
mean yes still gotta watch it so as this
is generally the structure that people
see my review system as it's like kind
of but for one major tweak it's not this
one's better than that one that one's
better than that one kind of thing there
is a hard line in there dividing that is
there to say and answer one simple
question thumbs up or thumbs down is it
good or is it not if it's on this side
it's good if it's on this side it's bad
and yeah good time if you're drunk it's
on both sides because it can be good it
can be bad
sometimes alcohol can enhance the movie
to be more fun because that's the kind
of movie it is or maybe you need alcohol
to get through them if one's positive
ones negative what to do watch the
review for context so that's my advice
when approaching my rating system see it
as a thumbs up or thumbs down everything
in the middle there is just semantics
its titles little one sentence one
phrase descriptions to describe the
movie generally speaking I imagine there
will be a number of people who will be
like yeah I know I know this is how it
works why'd you make this video but in
my personal experience I've got a lot of
people who don't they don't know this I
feel like they've been given a map with
no key so you can figure the map out
eventually but where the key makes it a
bit easier let this video be your key
this all may seem very illogical to some
people but hey this is my brain well so
now if for nothing else we have what
every thriving relationship has ene I
mean communication
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]